Michael why do you say that Talent
cannot be taught I think Talent is
something that that people just have or
they don't like if I had a script
a six-page audition for a television
show or a movie and I gave it to 100
people randomly on the street a certain
number of them would be able to look at
it read it and kind of make it
responsive and somewhat real
and many of them wouldn't that's I mean
the base level of talent from my
definition is having great first
instincts because you have to
particularly in film and television
there's no there's not a lot of
rehearsal there's not a lot of time to
sort of find your character and all that
stuff so your instincts are your first
instinct
if it's right about 75 80 percent of the
time that to me is the Baseline level of
the definition of talent I don't think
you can teach it you can teach strategy
you can teach people to be better with
what talent level they have
but I don't I think Talent is just
something people have or they don't and
and you see it in children I mean you
see it in little kids so I I
I don't know if that answers the
question but that's how I feel about it
instinct sure and and maybe give
it full sure
so
um when you're an actor is the is the
slave is too strong or where the actor
is obedient to the text
the text is everything at least that's
how I was taught that's how I was
trained and so the instinct is when you
look at something very quickly like if I
get an audition for for a TV show or a
movie
and there's very little time I look at
it quickly and I go because also I'm
seasoned and I've done this a long time
it's not like I'm a 23 year old anymore
so I could look at it and instantly have
a take on how it's supposed to go for me
it's rhythmical and it's outside in
meaning uh I work on externals and I
wasn't taught that fact that that was
oppositional to how I was taught
inside meaning uh
thinking about it wondering about it
dredging up some old experience in your
life to somehow illuminate it I work
with externals and so it it helps me
when you talk about the Instinct and
having the idea to just look at
something quickly we call that in the
business they call that a cold read like
here's a cold can you cold read this in
other words you just look at it and you
read it and you have something or you
don't
that's talent and that's Instinct and I
kind of don't think that can be taught I
think you either have that or you don't
training helps that I mean when you have
good foundational training
it helps that because you are in
practice and you're getting better at uh
being able to you you get better faster
we have particularly in film and
television you have to get better faster
you have to find a way to short circuit
and get to the results faster
so let's say you know how they mention
of people certain people have more
Street smarts than others or those in
combat certain people just kind of
thrive in those situations there's
something innate in them is that similar
to being on stage and working with
another person in front of you
yeah I think that's actually a really
good analogy it's interesting I I had a
woman in the very first class that I
taught who was a friend of mine from the
voiceover business and she was not an
actor
she was mostly a writer and a really
interesting creative person
highly creative highly imaginative funny
but not a trained actor but she wanted
to take this acting class
and she would come in every week with
results from the work she was doing
outside of class
that were weird and interesting and fun
and not typical actor stuff it was
off-center a little bit and I finally
said to her I just want to know because
you don't have
you really don't have a foundational
training that a lot of people have how
do you arrive at that what is your what
is your process
and she said well I just pretend that
what's happening is happening to me
I went okay we can all go home now
that's the lesson because that for film
acting in particular I come from the
theater originally but for film acting
it is a personal identity art form you
are the vessel through which the story
flows
I don't know if I answered your question
you did yeah did she continue on or she
just wanted to be there she just did
well she did for a while I think she was
in class for maybe a year and she had
fun and it was great for her and it I
think it helped
um it helps her other work which was
voice over and writing
because it's all kind of the same I mean
it's different it's in different silos
but it's really all the same it's all
the same Instinct it's all the same
creative impulse to do something look
when you have like I have two sons who
are grown up now and married and all
that but when they were little kids
they no one had to teach them to run
around the house with a hat on and
pretend they were a Power Ranger or
whatever it was they were pretending to
be that's just a human hardwired
instinct to play and transform
and I don't think that's taught I think
it is Vogler and I when I did the
interview with Chris Vogler talked about
story also being just sort of hardwired
into the species the hero and all of
that and little kids you see them doing
that I think with actors in particular
it's getting back to that original
impulse to play and transform that makes
it um
it but a lot of stuff gets in the way I
mean life gets in the way and and how
you're raised gets in the way and the
things you've been taught to behave
yourself and get in line and all that
stuff gets in the way and the people
were never got in the way are the people
who have an open Open Door
you know I say that with people I can
help you if the door is open if the door
is closed I mean nobody can can help you
so is that why with uh comedic timing as
well certain stand-ups let's say Robin
Williams
it was it was like some other being was
inside of him yeah I mean I think it is
I think it is I think it is
that's a really good question and I
don't really have a nuanced answer for
it but I do think I can remember when I
was a little kid
making people laugh and not knowing why
they were laughing but I knew how to do
it
but I wasn't sure why they were laughing
but I knew how to be funny
where does that come from I have no idea
but it was
um I I told the story yesterday to a
student of mine who came by for a for a
session and
I was talking about
um one of the things
I will not have a second book but if I
ever did have a second book it would be
called worlds and faces because I think
that's what TV and film is It's All
About Faces and worlds because everybody
at the professional level is pretty
talented so it's not about that it's
about where do you fit where does this
fit into that world
SWAT is a world NCIS is a world Downton
Abbey is a world they're all different
where do you fit it's all about fit so I
told her this story is comes back to
your question about comedic timing
I had an audition for Seinfeld
that I'd never been up for that show
that I always wanted to be on that show
because it's such a cool show it's still
a cool show it's still very funny
and I had this line uh first of all I
walked in the room and and Jerry
Seinfeld was in the room which
kind of freaked me out
um it was exciting you know because I
love him I still love him I think he's
brilliant and my first I'm trying I'm
working for the New York Mets and I'm
trying to get George to get himself
fired so he can come work for the Mets
and my first line is and it's not to me
it's not a funny line but the first line
is George the Mets need a new head of
scouting and we think that someone might
be you that's the line it's not really a
funny line I said that line
and Seinfeld almost fell off the chair
laughing and I thought
what just happened here
that's interesting
somehow I fit in that world he thought
that was funny for whatever reason I
don't know I can't quantify it but it's
I think it's just genetic when you talk
about Robin Williams or any of these
other brilliant
um comedic Minds I do think it is kind
of just you know when you're a little
kid you become the class clown you
become the one who entertains everybody
and if you're continue to be crazy
enough you become you become a stand-up
comedian
I and that scene is on your reel correct
I think it is yeah it's very funny
you're with you're in a diet at the
diner yeah
yeah we'll have a link to your real uh
down below people can look at it